the President also said yesterday this
is no time to walk away from Ukraine USA
to that country will be an issue in the
new Congress he's pushing for billions
more dollars in Aid on top of advanced
weapon systems and other assistants that
have already helped Ukraine's military
roll back Russian gains Holly Williams
spoke to Ukraine's former president
about that American Aid and why he
believes it's crucial
from rocket systems
anti-tank missiles American weapons have
been game changing in Ukraine helping
its soldiers recapture swards of
territory I'm appreciated first not
congressmen not Administration not even
the president but United States people
Petro poroshenko is a former president
of Ukraine who told us defeating
Vladimir Putin in this country is really
about defending democracy across the
Free World this is a fighting not only
for Ukraine this is fighting for United
States this is fighting for the whole
Western world but last month then House
minority leader Kevin McCarthy suggested
Republicans could reassess military
assistance to Ukraine if they won
control of Congress saying there should
be no blank check I mean that's a
criminal and quality fairy tale but
nonetheless that's what's coming from
the Republican side retired General Ben
Hodges Commander the U.S Army in Europe
he's also critical of Progressive
Democrats in Congress who wrote a letter
urging President Biden to use diplomacy
to somehow end the war before hastily
withdrawing it others in the U.S even
argue that Ukraine should give up
territory in return for peace would it
actually work if you do that kind of a
deal with Russia can you trust them
absolutely not and then I would ask
people so which part of their country or
their home state are they willing to
give up if Russia said hey look we just
want a little bit of Florida or let us
have New England and then we'll promise
not to use nuclear weapons so they're
pursuing the insane impeachment Witch
Hunt I've been former president Donald
Trump was impeached reached for abusive
power in 2019 after blocking nearly 400
million dollars in military assistance
to Ukraine and pressuring President
Vladimir zelenski to investigate
discredited corruption allegations
against his rival Joe Biden now some
ukrainians fear they could again be held
hostage to U.S politics my message to
all of my friend from both Democrat and
Republican it should be a competition
between you who do more for Ukrainian
resilience for the Global Security
this morning's Holly Williams key